Some trips are just better in an Airbnb. And right now, you can discover Canada and there are many local hidden gems with an Airbnb. I worked in Canada off and on for two years. Yes. And my first year, the production put me up at a place. And the second year, I was like, hey, whatever that production budget is, can I have it and go find my own place? And like more of a neighborhood, you know? Yes.
有些旅行，住Airbnb就是会更棒。而现在，你可以通过Airbnb探索加拿大，发掘许多本地的小众宝藏。我在加拿大断断续续工作了两年。是的。第一年，剧组给我安排了个住处。到了第二年，我说，嘿，不管那个制作预算是多少，能折现让我自己去找个住处吗？就像更有社区氛围那种，你懂的？没错。
And I did. I got an Airbnb. a little apartment. It faced a park. It was so lovely. I loved the host. And I stayed there for two months. Wow. Yeah. And I was near a grocery store. I really felt like I made a little life there. I'm thinking about like the Rocky Mountain areas in Canada where they've got the lakes and the Alberta Rockies. I don't know. It just feels like if you got yourself a cozy little cabin there, you know what I mean? Yeah. Like Banff, National Park. Well, listen, maybe you should consider Airbnb for your next adventure. I mean,
我照办了。我租了一间Airbnb，一个小公寓。它正对着一个公园。非常可爱。我很喜欢房东。我在那里住了两个月。哇。是的。而且我离杂货店很近。我真的觉得在那里过上了一种小日子。我在想加拿大落基山脉那些有湖泊和阿尔伯塔落基山脉的地方。我不知道。总觉得如果你能在那里拥有一间温馨的小木屋，你知道我的意思吗？对啊。就像班夫国家公园。听着，也许你的下一次冒险可以考虑一下Airbnb。我是说，
we love it. Love it. When you're with Amex Platinum, you get access to exclusive dining experiences and an annual travel credit. So the best tap is in town might be in a new town altogether. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Terms and conditions apply. Learn more at mx.ca. slash yamex. Hi. Hello.
我们太爱它了。超爱。使用运通白金卡，即可享专属餐饮体验和年度旅游积分。所以，城中最赞的酒吧可能就在一座全新城市之中。这就是运通的强大后盾。受条款及细则约束。了解详情请访问 mx.ca/yamex。嗨。你好。
Sam Cassie. Hi. Hello. Did you forget how to do this? Yeah. It's been a while. Yeah. Hi.
山姆，卡西。嗨。你好。你们忘怎么录这节目了吗？对啊。好久没录了。对。嗨。
Happy Friday chit chat everybody. Oh, I miss you guys. Wow. Sam, I am so here for your handlebar mustache. I think it's so hot. Really? I'm not a fan of it. I've just been.
祝大家周五闲聊愉快。噢，我想你们啦。哇。山姆，我太支持你的八字胡了。我觉得太性感了。真的吗？我不怎么喜欢。我只是。
I've been rocking it the last couple days. Did you lose a bet? Why are you, if you don't like it? I was shaving. All guys when they shave, they start with a beard, then we do weird moustaches and take photos and then shave it off. That's the process of shaving your beard off. And when I got to this stage,
这两天一直在留着。你打赌输了吗？既然你不喜欢，为什么还要留？我当时在刮胡子。所有男人刮胡子的时候，都是先留着胡须，然后搞出各种奇怪的胡子造型拍拍照，最后再把它全剃光。这就是刮胡子必经的过程。当我留到这个阶段时，
I had to go get something from the male and never picked up shaving again. So I'm like 80% done with shaving. Yeah, I've looked like this for the last couple days. Women are crossing the street when I walk up to them. Not this lady. Really? Not this lady. Okay.
我得去取个快递，结果就一直没再接着刮。所以我大概完成了80%的剃须。对，我顶着这个造型已经好几天了。我朝路人走过去时，女人们都在绕道走。这位女士可没有。真的吗？这位女士没有。好吧。
I'm saying God bless the mail is what I'm saying. Oh my gosh, we have so much to catch up on. How is everyone? Oh, good, good, good, good, good. How are you? I'm great. Wait, Sam, were you in Hawaii? Were you just in Hawaii?
我的意思是，感谢上帝送来的快递，我是这个意思。噢天哪，我们要聊的近况太多了。大家最近怎么样？噢，很好，很好，很好，很好。你呢？我很好。等等，山姆，你去了夏威夷吗？你刚去过夏威夷吗？
I was just in Waikiki for two full weeks. It was, I used to think I'd never been before. Everything looks like, you know how when in the Truman show where he sails out to the edge of the wall, realizes it's painted on? Everything looked painted on, like all the sunsets, all the ocean water. Everything looks fake, but it's all real. It was gorgeous. The water was gorgeous.
我刚在威基基呆了整整两周。那种感觉，我以前以为自己从没去过。一切看起来，你知道就像在《楚门的世界》里，他航行到墙的边缘，发现那是画上去的那种感觉吗？一切看起来都像是画出来的，比如所有的日落，所有的海水。一切看起来都很假，但全都是真的。美极了。水美极了。
Beautiful. Yeah, it was really nice. The people were so sweet. It was great. I love it. I always think pineapple tastes better in Hawaii. It's like so sweet. Do you know what I'm talking about?
太美了。对啊，真的很棒。当地人太友好了。太棒了。我很喜欢。我总觉得夏威夷的菠萝更好吃。超级甜。你知道我在说什么吗？
Yeah, I think it's because you're a little dehydrated. No. No. And Jenna, how's Chicago? Oh, lady. I just saw you. You were just here. I know.
对，我觉得那是因为你有点轻微脱水。才不是。不对。还有詹娜，芝加哥怎么样？噢，天哪。我才刚见过你。你刚才还在这里。我懂的。
I know, I know, but we got to see each other in a very sort of truncated little window of time. But you're living in Chicago. I mean, I left you a message. I was like, I love it there. I love it. Top new favorite city. Yeah, I think it's a good thing I didn't move to Chicago when I left St. Louis because I'm not sure I would have ever made it all the way to L.A.
我懂的，我懂的，但我们见面的时间窗口实在太短了。不过你现在住在芝加哥。我是说，我给你留过言。我说过，我太喜欢那里了。我太爱了。我心目中的最新最爱城市。对，我觉得我离开圣路易斯时没有搬到芝加哥可能是一件好事，因为我不敢确定自己当时是不是还能一路走到洛杉矶。
I think I would have stopped here. I am in love. Did you ever do Chicago Second City? Was that part of your comedy? No, no, no. The improv group that I started with, I-O-West, they're originally from Chicago, for the Pro-Olympic. Yeah.
我想我当时就会在这儿停下了。我彻底沦陷了。你以前参加过芝加哥的“第二城”剧团吗？那是你喜剧经历的一部分吗？没有，没有，没有。我最初加入的即兴表演团I-O-West，他们本来就来自芝加哥，为了奥运会。对。
No, but same, Jenna. I think if my first pit stop had been Chicago, I'd still be there. Yeah. It's amazing. I just swam in Lake Michigan this morning with my daughter. You did not. Really? That's so cool.
不，不过同理，詹娜。如果我的第一站是芝加哥，我现在可能还呆在那儿呢。对啊。太棒了。我今天早上还和女儿一起在密歇根湖游泳了。你才没有。真的吗？太酷了吧。
That has to be like a cold plunge. It's not that cold. It's wonderful. Really? Yeah, but you can handle the cold lady. You can handle the cold. I'd probably stick my big toe in there and be like, I'm out. I'm telling you.
那感觉一定像冬泳一样吧。没那么冷。棒极了。真的吗？对啊，不过你挺耐冻的，女士。你很耐冻。我大概把大脚趾伸进去就会说，我不行了。我跟你说。
It's not that cold. The end of the summer, it's so refreshing. It was, what, maybe 75 degrees out, but the sun was warm and the water was warm. And I could walk right up to Lakeshore Drive and go out on the beach. And it was just great. The play, which I'm doing at the Goodman Theater. Ashland Avenue is fantastic. Thank you, lady.
真没那么冷。夏天快结束时，感觉太清爽了。当时气温大概有75华氏度吧，但阳光很暖和，水也很暖和。我可以一直走到湖滨大道，然后去海滩上。感觉棒极了。我在古德曼剧院演出的那部话剧。阿什兰大道，太棒了。谢谢你，女士。
So good. We just opened. Oh, my gosh. I just wasn't prepared for how much I was going to, how emotional I was going to get on so many different like layers because I was so proud of you, Jenna, and you are so good. And I got to see my friend have this moment that I know she just where she's her full self. And then the performances are so great that like I was just, I was crying and then I was laughing, all the things. Well, lady, thank you for saying that because I do feel like I'm getting to express my full self.
太棒了。我们刚刚开演。噢，天哪。我简直没有心理准备，没想到自己会在那么多不同的层面上变得如此感性、如此情绪激动，因为我为你感到无比骄傲，詹娜，你演得太棒了。我看着我的朋友迎来了这个高光时刻，我知道这正是她完全做自己的时刻。而且演出效果太棒了，我一边哭一边笑，百感交集。好吧，女士，谢谢你这么说，因为我确实觉得我正在表达最完整的自我。
And I will tell you, I am definitely 100% at home in the theater with my theater nerd people. Like, these are my people. Oh, nice. Just a hundred percent. And lady, I've talked to you about the crew on this. I love them like I love our office crew. Nikki, our stage manager. Oh, my God.
而且我得告诉你，在剧院里和我那些戏剧迷朋友们在一起，我百分之百找到了家的感觉。真的，这些就是我的同道中人。噢，太好了。百分之百。而且女士，我跟你聊过这里的剧组。我爱他们就像爱我们办公室的工作人员一样。妮基，我们的舞台经理。噢，天哪。
Stop it. She's so good. All the things a stage manager has to do. She's like the Kelly Cantley of Ashland Avenue. She's like our first AD. She does like. all the scheduling. But she also makes all the little announcements on the microphone that I hear back in my dressing room. So she'll be like fight call actors who need to do fight call. Please come to the
别说了。她太棒了。舞台经理要处理的杂务可真多啊。她简直就是阿什兰大道的凯利·坎特利。她就像我们的第一副导演。她负责诸如。所有的排期安排。但她还会在我化妆间能听到的麦克风里做各种小广播。所以她会说：“打斗戏演员请注意，需要进行打斗戏排练的人员请立刻到”
stage now for fight call. But then it's like the sweetest little voice. But then my favorite is like at the end of a show, she'll be like, all right, everybody, that's another performance. We have finished wonderful cast of Ashland Avenue. I'm going to see you back tomorrow at 1.30. 1.30 is your half hour call 115 if you're coming for fight call it's like i need to record it it's the cutest thing i just love her but i mean i love everybody andria is the gal who sits outside my dressing room at a little table and she is my i guess dresser my wardrobe person she dresses me and fran who is the um the guy who plays my dad in the play our dressing rooms are side by side and she sits outside with like the rack of clothes and it's her job before i go on stage every time to check
“舞台集合进行打斗戏排练。”然后她的声音听起来甜美极了。不过我最喜欢的还是演出快结束时，她会说：“好了，各位，又完成了一场演出。我们完成了精彩的《阿什兰大道》演员阵容。明天下午1:30见。1:30是前半小时催场，如果要参加打斗戏排练的请在1:15到场。”我真想把它录下来，太可爱了。我简直爱死她了。不过我是说，我爱这里的每一个人。安德烈娅就是坐在我化妆间外一张小桌子旁的那位姑娘，她算是我的服装助理吧，负责帮我换衣服。还有弗兰，也就是在剧中扮演我爸爸的那个家伙，我们的化妆间紧挨着。她就坐在外面，旁边挂着衣架，每次我上台前，她的工作就是检查
make sure I have the right stuff on. And you would think, like, oh, you'll have the right stuff on. I cannot tell you how many times, like, I'll go back after a scene and I'll sit down. I'll, like, reapply my lipstick. I'll, like, look at my lines, make sure I know what I'm doing. And I'll walk out. I'll have the complete wrong shoes on. Or I'll, like, have forgotten to change my sweater.
确保我穿对了衣服。你可能会想，哦，肯定能穿对衣服。我简直无法向你形容，有多少次，比如我演完一场戏回到后台坐下。我开始补口红。我开始对台词，确保我知道自己在做什么。然后我走出去。结果穿了完全不对的鞋子。或者忘记换上毛衣。
And Andrea will be like, sweater, sweater. But I mean, I just, that's what I mean. I, like, just love all of them. And I love her. And I just, everybody. Lauren Gabe, I mean, I could just name so many people who just are so meaningful behind the scenes. And I am. I'm just living out my dream, lady.
安德烈娅就会喊：“毛衣，毛衣。”我是说，这就是我的意思。我就是，我爱他们每一个人。我爱她，爱所有人。劳伦·盖布，我是说我可以列举出好多人，他们在幕后付出了如此意义重大的努力。而我。我正在实现我的梦想，女士。
And what I was saying about the Goodman is that I'm staying about a 30-minute walk from the theater. So I can even walk there if I want. Oh, that's nice. And I get to walk past the river. And it's a beautiful walk. I mean, it's just this city is incredible. Nice. And I'm so proud of Lee.
我刚才说到古德曼剧院，我住的地方离剧院大约步行30分钟。所以我甚至可以走着去，如果我想的话。哦，那挺好的。而且我还能沿着河边走。那是一段很美的步行路程。我是说，这座城市简直不可思议。太好了。我为李感到骄傲。
His play is so good. And it's really getting a chance to shine. It's been great. This question is on behalf of the Office Ladies fan Facebook club. Jenna, do you come out afterwards and take pictures and sign stuff? I have. I have come out every night except opening. They had a special event that we attended as a cast,
他的剧本太棒了。而且它真的迎来了大放异彩的机会。太棒了。这个问题是代表“办公室女士”粉丝脸书俱乐部问的。詹娜，演出结束后你会出来合影和签名吗？我会的。除了首演之夜，我每晚都会出来。那天剧组安排了一个特别活动，我们需要出席，
so I wasn't able to come out on opening night. But thank you for bringing that up, Sam, because I do want to give a shout out to the Office Ladies community. Every night during previews, there was some group of people from Office Ladies. that came out to support the show. And if theater nerds are not my people, then my people are office ladies people.
所以在首演之夜我没能出来。不过谢谢你提起这个，山姆，因为我确实想向“办公室女士”的社群表达感谢。在预演期间的每一晚，都会有一群“办公室女士”的粉丝。特意跑来看演出支持我们。如果说戏剧迷不是我的同道中人，那“办公室女士”的粉丝绝对是我的同道中人。
These are my two people. Because every group of women that I met and husbands, oh my gosh, I have so many stories, one gal flew in all the way from Brazil by herself to see Ashland Avenue. Yes. And then another woman, she grabbed me and she said, will you please take a picture with my husband
这两类人都是我的贴心人。因为我遇到的每一群女性以及她们的丈夫——噢，天哪，我有太多故事了。有一位姑娘一个人从巴西大老远飞过来，只为了看《阿什兰大道》。是的。还有另一位女士，她拉住我说：“你能跟我丈夫拍张照吗”
because he loves you. He loves you. You're the love of his life. And I was like, sure, I'll take a picture with your husband. And she said, he listens to office ladies. He told me about this play. He told me Angela has a cookbook coming out. He knows all y'all's business.
“因为他太喜欢你了。他超爱你的。你是他生命中的挚爱。”我当时就想：“没问题，我很乐意跟你丈夫合影。”然后她说：“他一直在听《办公室女士》。他跟我讲了这部剧。他告诉我安吉拉要出一本食谱。你们的事他全都知道。”
He loves you. He talks about you guys all the time. You're like, like you're his friends in our house, and he tells me your stories. So it was so cute. But yeah, it's been great. So when they, you know, when I'm allowed to come out, then I do come out and say hi to people, of course. I mean, it's just amazing.
“他太喜欢你了。他总是提起你们。你们就像，就像我们家里的朋友一样，他把你们的故事讲给我听。”所以这真的太可爱了。不过对啊，真的很棒。所以当他们，你知道的，当我被允许出来时，我当然会出来跟大伙儿打招呼。我是说，这实在太美妙了。
I went on and on, you guys. Thank you. No, no. This is Friday chit-chat. This is Friday chit-chat. Yeah. Angela, you have been to Iceland, and you have specifically now,
我滔滔不绝说个没完，伙计们。谢谢。没事，没事。这就是周五闲聊。这就是周五闲聊。对啊。安吉拉，你去了冰岛，而且你现在专门，
you have not shared with me about the P penis museum. You said I had to wait until this Friday chit-chat. So I don't say it. I saved it. I say, hell yeah, I went. Yeah. You had to. By the way, it's right in the middle of like little downtown Reykjavik.
你之前一直没有跟我讲阴茎博物馆的事。你说我得等到今天的周五闲聊才能听。所以我一直没说。我憋着呢。我想说，去他的，我确实去了。对啊。你必须得去。顺便说一句，它就在雷克雅未克市中心的正中央。
You can't miss it. Like, it's right there. Yes, I went to the Beanus Museum. Okay, for those of you that didn't hear us break down the episode, The Sting, remember when Dwight is trying to intimidate Danny Cordray and he like walks into the lobby? And he's like, she says, that's the biggest penis I've ever seen. And I said, I know. That's why I brought you to the penis museum where tickets are $1,000.
你绝对不会错过。就在那儿。没错，我去了阴茎博物馆。好了，对于那些没有听我们解析《绝招》那一集的人，还记得德怀特试图恐吓丹尼·科德雷时，他走进大堂的情节吗？他说，她说过，这是我见过的最大的阴茎。我说，我知道。这就是为什么我带你来阴茎博物馆，这里的门票要1000美元。
That whole bit, we were like, is that real? Yeah. Didn't a fan write in and say that it was a real place? Yes, it is a real place. It's in Recovac, Iceland, and I went, I should say, that the penises are animals. They're animal penises, okay? It's not like, it's not a human penis.
对于整个这个包袱，我们当时就在想：这是真的吗？对啊。难道没有粉丝写信说这是个真实的地方吗？是的，这真的是个地方。它在冰岛的雷克雅未克，我去了。我得说明一下，这些阴茎都是动物的。它们是动物的阴茎，好吧？它不是那种，不是人类的阴茎。
But anyway, I went. I mean, we've always said, if we ever got to Iceland, we'd have to go. Yeah, you had to go. I had to go. And so I did. Josh was like, our first day there, you know, we're a little tired. little jet laggy. First of all, do you know, people in Iceland love to go get ice cream or gelato?
不管怎样，我去看了。我是说，我们一直说过，如果我们有机会去冰岛，一定要去看看。对啊，你非去不可。我必须得去。于是我就去了。乔治当时就说，我们到那儿的第一天，你知道的，大家都有些累。还有点时差。首先，你知道吗，冰岛人特别喜欢去买冰淇淋或意式冰淇淋？
It's like a big deal. Like, they have their own word. It's a very long word. I'm not going to attempt to say it. But it literally means let's all go get ice cream. And it doesn't matter if it's like freezing out. And it doesn't matter. You're going to get ice cream.
这算是一件大事。而且，他们有自己的专属词汇。那是一个非常长的词。我可不去尝试发音了。但它字面上的意思就是“我们一起去买冰淇淋吧”。而且不管外面是不是冷得要命。这都无所谓。你就是得去吃冰淇淋。
Anyway, so we, of course, got recommended at a great gelato place. And we're going there. And I said to Josh, I'm like, oh, man, I wish I should have looked up where the penis museum was we could have gone by it when we were out to get gelato and he said and we've walked past it three times i was like what he goes he clocked it said ang you didn't see the penis shape rock out on the sidewalk and there is a big rock with two little balls of rocks next to it and i'm like oh yeah oh and then you you go in and you go downstairs and you're in and you're in The penis museum.
不管怎样，我们当然推荐了一家很棒的冰淇淋店。然后我们要去那儿。我对乔什说，哦，天哪，我真希望我之前查一下阴茎博物馆在哪里，这样我们去买冰淇淋的时候就能顺便路过了，他说我们已经走过它三次了，我说什么，他说他注意到了，说安，你没看到人行道上那个阴茎形状的岩石吗，那是一块大石头，旁边还有两块小石头，然后我说，哦，对，哦，接着你走进去，下楼，你就身处阴茎博物馆了。
So first of all, we have huge office fans in Iceland. And in particular, they work at the penis museum. Really? I took photos. They were so tickled. I was there. And yeah, it's very interesting, you guys. It's a lot of penises.
所以首先，冰岛有很大的办公室粉丝。特别是，他们在阴茎博物馆工作。真的吗？我拍了照片。他们觉得太逗了。我在那儿。是的，非常有意思，伙俩。有大量的阴茎。
Penises and glass. Yeah. And, of course, I had to bring you all a gift from Iceland from the penis museum. Oh, my God. You know, okay, so it is the Icelandic pathological museum, I should say it correctly. Sam, I'm going to go with your gift first. I really agonized over this because there were some really great t-shirts. Okay.
阴茎和玻璃。对。而且，我当然得从冰岛、从阴茎博物馆给你们带一件礼物。哦，天哪。你知道，好吧，这是冰岛阴茎博物馆，我应该准确地说出它的名字。萨姆，我先送你的礼物。我为此真的很纠结，因为有一些非常棒T恤。好吧。
Really great. Lay it out of it. And I'll take pictures and put it in stories. Just read, read Sam what the bottom says. It's all about dicks. I'm going to pop the sleeves off that right away. I know. It's perfect.
非常棒。拿出来吧。我会拍照片发到快拍里。萨姆，读一下底部的字。全是关于鸡巴的。我马上要把那件衣服的袖子剪掉。我知道。太完美了。
Thank you. So there you go. Jenna, I got us each one. and then we can take them in our office. We got a penis coffee mug. No. Oh my gosh. It really is a mug with a penis on it.
谢谢。给你。珍娜，我们俩人手一个。然后我们可以把它带到办公室。我们买了一个阴茎咖啡杯。不会吧。哦，天哪。这真的就是一个印有阴茎的杯子。
Yeah, it is. Wow. Also, Cassie, same slogan for you in a tote bag. Great. I love a toe. I can't wait for you to carry this around L.A. It's all about dicks. Yeah.
对，就是。哇。还有，卡西，你也有一个印有同样标语的手提袋。太好了。我喜欢手提袋。我等不及看你带着它在洛杉矶到处走了。全是关于鸡巴的。对。
But it was very interesting. It was. I took a picture next to the sperm well penis. That is a sight to behold. But, yeah, Iceland was so low. Everyone there is so kind and nice and you just get out in nature and people are really earnest, you know? I loved everyone there. I made a really good friend, Yoie.
但这真的很有趣。确实。我在抹香鲸阴茎旁边拍了照。那真是一个壮观的景象。不过，冰岛真的很低调。那里的每个人都那么善良友好，你只要去大自然中，人们真的很真诚，你知道吗？我喜欢那里的每个人。我交了一个非常好的朋友，约伊。
Shout out to Yoie. He's the best and I can't wait to go back. Yeah, I can't say enough things about it. It's gorgeous. It's beautiful. And I really think we need to have an office ladies road trip to Recovic. Everyone there loves the office. We should go hang out.
向约伊致敬。他最棒了，我迫不及待想再回去。对，我怎么夸它都不够。太壮观了。太美了。我真的觉得我们需要来一次“办公室女士”雷克雅未克公路旅行。那里的每个人都喜欢《办公室》。我们应该去逛逛。
I love that idea. I mean, after your trip, you told me you wanted to move there. yes now to be fair i know this is something i do josh says it's something i do it wherever we go we're on a road trip i start to like look up houses there like could we live here and i keep thinking i can live in a lot of places but iceland is one of them okay but angela you also had an insane tennis adventure trip that you got to tell them about i know so i shared this with cassie but i haven't shared it with Sam and Jenna. So, you know, Cassie and I both are, you know, we have our passion. Mine for tennis. Cassie's is for basketball. And I was like Cassie, I got to do
我很喜欢这个主意。我是说，旅行结束后，你告诉我你想搬到那里去。是的，平心而论，我知道这是我会做的事，乔什说这是我无论走到哪里都会做的事，我们在进行公路旅行时，我开始喜欢查那里的房子，就像我们能住在这里吗，我一直觉得我可以住在很多地方，但冰岛是其中之一。好吧，不过安吉拉，你还有一次疯狂的网球冒险之旅，你得跟他们讲讲。我知道，所以我跟卡西分享了这件事，但还没跟萨姆和珍娜分享。所以，你们知道，卡西和我都有我们的热情所在。我的是网球。卡西的是篮球。我对卡西说，我必须去做
basically the Super Bowl in my life for tennis. And I was invited to play you guys at the Tennis Hall of Fame, the International Tennis Hall of Fame. It's the oldest courts in the United States. They're grass courts. It's in Newport, Rhode Island. Oh, Sam. Sam. It was. first of all, Maria Sharpova's induction ceremony and the Brian Brothers. Jeez. And so I played with Arancha Sanchez Vicario, who is amazing. I met Kim Kleisters. Okay.
基本上是我网球人生中的超级碗。我被邀请去打网球名人堂，国际网球名人堂。那是美国最古老的球场。它们是草地球场。它在罗德岛州纽波特。哦，萨姆。萨姆。真的是。首先，玛丽亚·莎拉波娃的入选仪式还有布莱恩兄弟。天哪。所以我跟阿兰查·桑切斯·维卡里奥一起打了球，她太棒了。我遇到了金·克莱斯特斯。好吧。
You name it. I met them. I also played with the Brian brothers. And, and, okay, I have to just tell one story. If you can tell how dear on headlights I was. Oh, and by the way, Chris Everett and Tracy Austin watched my match. I was so embarrassed. If I didn't get a good shot, I was like, oh, they were right there.
你能说出名字的。我都遇到了。我还跟布莱恩兄弟打过球。而且，而且，好吧，我必须讲一个故事。如果你能看出我当时有多像惊吓的小鹿。哦，顺便说一下，克里斯·埃弗特和特雷西·奥斯汀观看了我的比赛。我当时太尴尬了。如果我没打好一个球，我就想，哦，他们就在那儿。
And Ruey Sharapopo was there for the beginning. How did you play? Did you play well? I mean, decent. Yes. I had some winners. I had a clunky backhand, but I had some winners. You know what?
鲁伊·莎拉波波也在开场时出席了。你打得怎么样？你打得好吗？我是说，还不错。是的。我打出了一些制胜分。我的反手有点笨拙，但我有制胜分。你知道吗？
And we were miced, and I was so worried about cursing, and I did say shit four times. But I think all in all, that was okay if you're going to say one. Yeah. But, I mean, let me tell you, the Brian brothers don't hold back, and they whizzed a few at me. And I was like, oh, shit. But I have to tell this story It's the very beginning of the match And Maria Sharapova is standing right next to me
而且我们身上带着麦克风，我非常担心说脏话，我确实说了四次“操”。但我觉得总的来说，如果你要说一次的话，那也还好。对。但是，我的意思是，跟你说吧，布莱恩兄弟可不会手软，他们朝我呼啸着打了好几球。当时我就想，哦，操。但我必须讲这个故事，这是比赛刚开始的时候，玛丽亚·莎拉波娃就站在我旁边
With Kim Kleisters and Andy Roddick And they're like, Angela, you're going to do the coin toss But it went in my brain like this You're going to do the coin I was like what And they hand me this coin And I turned to Maria Sharapova and I go, you do it She's like what?
还有金·克莱斯特斯和安迪·罗迪克。他们说，安吉拉，你要去抛硬币。但我的大脑里是这样的：你要去抛硬……我当时想，什么。然后他们把这枚硬币递给我。我转过身对玛丽亚·莎拉波娃说，你来吧。她说，什么？
And Kim's like Kim's like, Angela, you're the coin. And I was like, I don't know. And then so. I don't know how to flip a coin. And I was just like so. And so then we kind of clunky hand off the coin and she flips it anyway. But I just can't believe I turned Maria Sharapova.
金说，金说，安吉拉，是你抛硬币。然后我说，我不知道。然后呢。我不知道怎么抛硬币。然后我就那样。接着我们有点笨拙地把硬币交接了一下，反正她把硬币抛了。但我简直不敢相信我转向了玛丽亚·莎拉波娃。
And I'm like, you do it. Like, you tried to pawn your special gift off on someone else. I just was so like I just couldn't believe I was standing in front of them. And I just completely computer shut down, you know, in my brain. What kind of coin was it? Was it just a quarter? Was it a silver dollar? was it a special tennis coin? What was it? I always wonder what coins they use in these coin tosses.
然后我说，你来吧。就像，你试图把你的特殊礼物推给别人一样。我当时太……我简直不敢相信自己站在他们面前。然后我的大脑彻底死机了，你知道的。那是什么硬币？只是一个25美分硬币吗？是一个银元吗？是一个特殊的网球硬币吗？是什么？我一直好奇这些抛硬币环节用的是什么硬币。
Lady, if I was in my body at all, I could tell you. Well, when you go back in your mind, did it was... It was bigger than a quarter. It was a larger than a quarter coin. Okay. Yes. I thought it was a special tennis. I don't know. I'll have to... Oh, by the way, I now text with Kim Kleister's, okay? Her daughter is a big office fan. And so I'm just going to name drop that. I will text Kim and ask her. Can you remember the coin? that I didn't toss? What was it? I might have a big name drop brag, too.
大姐，如果我当时清醒的话，我还能告诉你。嗯，当你回想的时候，它……它比25美分硬币大。它是一个比25美分硬币更大的硬币。好吧。是的。我以为那是一个特殊的网球。我不知道。我得……哦，顺便说一句，我现在跟金·克莱斯特斯发短信呢，好吗？她的女儿是《办公室》的超级粉丝。所以我主要就是想借此炫耀一下。我会发短信问问金。你还记得那枚硬币吗？我没抛的那枚？是什么？我可能也会有一个超级大咖炫耀。
What? Well, you were there on opening night of Ashland Avenue, and you saw that I had a few special guests. My parents were there. My kids were there. Lee's brother and sister were there. And then my manager, Naomi, and Bob, Odin Kirk, were there. And I'm so sorry. Hold on.
什么？好吧，你在《艾什兰大道》的首演之夜也在现场，你看到我有一些特别嘉宾。我的父母在那儿。我的孩子们在那儿。莉的兄弟姐妹在那儿。然后我的经纪人娜奥米和鲍勃·奥登科克也在那儿。非常抱歉。等等。
That's a big moment, because this story has a great ending. Mr. Eddie Vedder was there. No. So it is a very long story how I know Eddie Vedder and then also how we became reacquainted. I will tell that another time, but I have to tell this story, which is that today, he sent me a text. He's so incredibly supportive and sweet, especially like as an artistic mentor.
这是一个重大时刻，因为这个故事有一个美好的结局。埃迪·韦德先生也在那儿。不会吧。所以这是一个很长的故事，关于我怎么认识埃迪·韦德，以及我们后来又是怎么重新联系上的。我改天再讲这个，但我必须讲这个故事，那就是今天，他给我发了一条短信。他真的非常支持我，人也特别好，尤其是在艺术导师这方面。
And he was so taken with the play and has said so many nice things. And he just texted me today that he has something that he has something, that he he would like us to add to the set that he believes should live in the TV shop that is our set. And I don't know what it is, but he's like, I need your address immediately so I can send it to you. And if you could maybe, maybe you would want to add it to the set. Is that the coolest thing that there might be like some extra little wrap up on the set? What's it going to be? You have to tell us we'll need an update. I know. I don't know. He hasn't told me. What is this set? What What time period does it take place? Does it change? No, it's one set and it's a TV store, but it's this TV store that has been there for 40 years. So it's this beautiful set and it has been, you can see that there's like televisions from every era. So it's sort of half museum, half television store. It has modern televisions for sale and, you know, things like that, television parts. But there's this wall of just,
他太喜欢这部剧了，并说了那么多好听的话。他今天刚发短信给我说，他有样东西，他有样东西，他希望我们能把它加到布景里，他认为它应该留在作为我们布景的电视店里。我不知道那是什么，但他说，我马上需要你的地址，这样我才能寄给你。如果你可以的话，也许，也许你会想把它加到布景里。这难道不是最酷的事情吗，布景里可能会有一些额外的小彩蛋？那会是什么？你得告诉我们，我们需要更新。我知道。我不知道。他还没告诉我。这是一个什么样的布景？它发生在什么时期？它会变吗？不，这是一个布景，是一家电视店，但这家电视店已经开业40年了。所以这是一个非常漂亮的布景，而且它一直都在，你能看到里面有各个时代的电视机。所以它有点半是博物馆，半是电视店。里面有现代的电视机在售，你知道，诸如此类的东西，电视零件。但有一面墙上全都是，
like every old TV you could imagine through the ages. A hundred percent feels like a story you would walk in. Like, you know, it reminded me of like where we went to get my grandparents' TV, you know? Yeah. It's so cool. The set is so cool. I did round the corner. I rounded the corner and I saw Eddie Vedder gushing to Lee about how much the play meant to him and how layered it was for him.
就像你能想象的各个年代的每台旧电视。百分之百感觉就像是一个你会走进的故事。就像，你知道，它让我想起我们去买我祖父母的电视的地方，你知道吗？对。太酷了。这个布景太酷了。我拐过弯。我拐过弯，看到埃迪·韦德在向莉滔滔不绝地讲述这部剧对他的意义有多重大，以及对他来说层次有多丰富。
And I was like, wow, that's got to be. that's got to be feel pretty amazing maybe he has like a little tiny TV yeah I don't know vintage TV I'm not sure there's a lot of sports references in the play as well and um oh by the way Kevin Deppinette is who did the set design I had to like shout him out um but uh yeah so I don't know if it's a sportsy thing or a TV thing or if it's what is a Chicago thing maybe a Chicago thing he's got a rich Chicago history so yeah yeah oh i can't wait to see what it is well cassie i have to um ask you about your trip because i sent you a very long email with all of my tips for vancouver but you guys were you were very helpful you were going you went to vancouver but then from there didn't you go to victoria island we went to victoria and we went to seattle and i feel like this episode is the theme of like travel travel and name dropping so i just want to say when i was in seattle i was like of course I'm going to go to a WMBA game.
当时我想，哇，那一定。那感觉一定相当不可思议。也许他有一个小小的电视机。对，我不知道，复古电视，我不确定。剧中也有很多体育方面的梗，而且，哦，顺便说一句，凯文·德皮内特负责布景设计，我必须得感谢他一下。但是，哦，是的，所以，我不知道这是一个体育梗还是一个电视梗，或者如果它是……芝加哥梗？也许是一个芝加哥梗，他有着丰富的芝加哥历史，所以，对，对。哦，我迫不及待想看看那是什么了。好吧，卡西，我得……问问你的旅行，因为我给你发了一封很长的电子邮件，里面有我关于温哥华的所有建议，但你们去了，你们非常乐于助人，你们去了温哥华，但从那里，你们难道不是去了维多利亚岛吗？我们去了维多利亚，我们去了西雅图，我觉得这一集的的主题就是旅行旅行和掉书袋，所以我只想说，当我在西雅图的时候，我想，我当然要去观看一场WNBA比赛。
Yeah. So we got tickets for the storm and then realized that that game was going to be the unveiling of Sue Bird's statue. Oh, really? So we looked it up and they're like, yeah, get there at 10 a.m. And we get there and like all these like WMBA stars and stuff are there. And of course, Sue and her wife Meg are there and the mayor of Seattle's there. And they're like, we deemed this day Sue. bird day and it was just like celebrating a woman and it was the first wmba statue ever to be unveiled
对。所以我们买到了风暴队的门票，然后意识到那场比赛将是苏·伯德雕像的揭幕仪式。哦，真的吗？所以我们查了一下，他们说，对，上午10点到那儿。我们到了那儿，发现所有这些WNBA明星什么的都在那儿。当然，苏和她的妻子梅格也在那儿，西雅图市长也在那儿。他们说，我们把这一天定为苏·伯德日，这就像是为了致敬一位女性，而且这是第一座揭幕的WNBA雕像
which is wild to me wow how cool is that and did you meet were you able to like meet anyone or take a picture uh no but but it was just like cool to be there in that moment it was just by happenstance and like it was like one of the best full days because like even the space needle had like a little Sue Bird flag hanging in the morning. And it was just like really cool and empowering. And I was just like, I'm really glad to be here in this moment. And how special too? I feel like those moments are so special on their own, but then to sort of like find it on the fly. And all of a sudden it's such a memorable moment of your trip. It was really, really cool. That's really cool. Yeah. And then I took pictures with the statue. So I can send that to you. Maybe one day I'll actually get to meet Sue Bird. But
这对我来说太疯狂了。哇，太酷了。你遇到了吗，你有机会见到什么人或者拍张照吗？呃，没有，但能够在那一刻身处现场真的很酷。这完全是个巧合，而且就像是度过了最完美的一整天，因为甚至连太空针塔早上都挂着一面苏·伯德的小旗帜。这真的非常酷，而且充满赋能感。当时我就想，我真的很高兴能在这个时刻来到这里。而且也太特别了吧？我觉得这些时刻本身就很特别，然后又是这样意外发现的。突然间它成了你旅行中一个如此难忘的时刻。真的非常、非常酷。真的很酷。对。然后我跟雕像合影了。所以我可以把它发给你。也许有一天我真的能见到苏·伯德。但
that's really cool this was so fun I've missed you guys I know I like that our theme is travel and name dropping I like that you named it Cassie that's pretty good Sam do you have any other traveler name dropping to do
这真的很酷。这太有趣了。我非常想念你们。我知道，我喜欢我们的主题是旅行和掉书袋。我喜欢你给它起的名字，卡西，这挺不错的。萨姆，你还有其他旅行或掉书袋的事情要分享吗？
before we go no I don't I haven't met anyone famous lately I think it's the mustache no it is not I'm telling you it is not it is giving me major like Pedro Pascal I'm here for it Okay.
在我们离开之前？没有，我没有。我最近没有遇到什么名人。我想是因为这个胡子。不，不是这样的。我向你保证，绝对不是。这给我一种非常强烈的佩德罗·帕斯卡的感觉。我支持这个造型。好吧。
All right. Yeah. I'm just saying. Okay. I would keep it a little bit longer. All right. I'll write it out as long as I can. Okay.
好吧。对。我只是说说。好吧。我会再留一段时间。好吧，我能留多久就留多久。好吧。
Well, guys, this was awesome. I'm glad we were able to do this. Oh, wait, Jenna. What? Your play was extended, right? Yes. My play has been extended through October 12th. Okay.
好吧，伙计们，这太棒了。我很高兴我们能聚在一起。哦，等等，珍娜。什么？你的剧延期了，对吧？对。我的剧已经延期到10月12日了。好吧。
That's so exciting. Yeah. Well, you guys are all going to have to give me stuff for our office ladies' Insta stories because Sam, I think we need a picture of you. Yeah, I will. Yeah. I will. and I need one from Hawaii.
太令人兴奋了。对。好吧，你们都得为我们的“办公室女士”Ins快拍提供点素材，因为萨姆，我觉得我们需要一张你的照片。对，我会的。对。我会的。我还需要一张夏威夷的。
I need Sue Bird. Yeah. Jenna, I need Chicago. You know, I need you next to the penis rock outside. I'm curious if it's taller than you are. It isn't, Sam. It isn't taller than me, but the sperm is not penis. Really?
我需要苏·伯德。对。珍娜，我需要芝加哥的。你知道，我需要你站在外面那块阴茎岩石旁边。我很想知道它有没有你高。没有，萨姆。它没有我高，但那个精子可不是阴茎。真的吗？
The rock isn't, but the sperm will penis was. Okay. Good, good, good. Yeah. There you go. And thank you to everybody in the office ladies community for all of your support, while I've been here doing the play, thank you for coming out for it. But also, like, thank you guys for helping create this time for me. I mean, I'm going to get weepy if I talk about it too much,
岩石没有，但抹香鲸阴茎有。好吧，好，好。对。就这样。感谢“办公室女士”社群里的每一个人，感谢你们在我在这里演话剧期间给予的所有支持，谢谢你们来看演出。而且，谢谢你们帮我创造了这段属于我的时间。我是说，我要是再说下去就要哭出来了，
but I haven't been to a doctor's appointment in six weeks, and that is really cool. And it feels good. And I am just all about being an actress and a mom right now, and it feels so good. And I just, I thank you. Thank you. This has been like the end-all, be-all greatest experience. I can't, I can't even believe it. It's been the office of getting to do a play. We're so thrilled for you and we're so happy to help make the space. I think office ladies, we go pee when we want to pee. We always have cake on our birthday and we get to- As many pockets as we want. We have as many pockets as we want and we get to make space for each other to pursue our passions. And this community has been so wonderful and supportive. So I'm, I'm, um, I'm happy for you, lady. Thank you. Thanks,
但我已经六周没去过医生预约了，这真的很酷。而且感觉很好。我现在全心全意只想当个演员和妈妈，这种感觉太棒了。我只想说谢谢。谢谢你们。这简直就是终极的、最棒的体验。我甚至无法相信。这就是演一话剧的《办公室》。我们为你感到无比激动，也为能帮你腾出空间感到非常高兴。我觉得“办公室女士”们，想嘘嘘的时候就去嘘嘘。我们生日的时候总是有蛋糕，而且我们- 我们想要多少口袋就要多少口袋。我们想要多少口袋就要多少口袋，而且我们为彼此腾出空间去追求各自的热情。这个社群如此美好且充满支持。所以我，我，嗯，我为你感到高兴，女士。谢谢。谢谢，
guys. I love you all so much. I love you. I love you. Bye. Bye. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins, our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Calling all book lovers. The Toronto International Festival of Authors brings you a world of stories all in one place. Discover five days of readings, talks, workshops and more,
伙计们。我太爱你们了。我爱你们。我爱你们。再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。“办公室女士”是奥德赛（Audyssey）的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。奥德赛的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉特（Creed Bratton）的《橡胶树》。呼吁所有书迷。多伦多国际作家节为您在一个地方呈现精彩纷呈的故事世界。探索为期五天的朗诵、讲座、工作坊及更多精彩活动，
with over 100 authors from around the world, including Rachel Maddow, Ketourou Isaku and Kieran Desai. The Toronto International Festival of Authors, October 29th to November 2nd. Details and tickets at Festival of Authors.ca. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
汇聚了来自世界各地的100多位作家，包括瑞秋·马多、奇图鲁·伊萨库和基兰·德赛。多伦多国际作家节，10月29日至11月2日。详情与门票请访问 Festival of Authors.ca。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。